[Musique]
dépouille de la reine poursuit sa route
c'est suivi de ces quatre enfants dont
un désormais roi que le cortège funèbre
a quitté le palais de Hollywood pour la
cathédrale Sainte James à Édimbourg sous
le regard souvent silencieux du public
massif le long du royaume Maël le mil
Royal ces royaumes n'étaient sans doute
plus que des enfants orphelins
c'est à ça que pensez les ânes son fils
endormi dans ses bras voyant le roi
Charles arrivé aux portes de la
cathédrale d'Ital
Elisabeth II était chez elle en Écosse
nombreux sont ceux dans la foule qui
peuvent raconter une histoire ou deux
d'une rencontre brève fortuite
personnelle avec la reine mais peu en
ont autant que la comtesse de Manneville
je viens d'un endroit qui s'appelle
school Palace là où en couronne les rois
d'Écosse et la reine est venue très
souvent au palais elle se rappelle d'une
femme drôle intelligente et chaleureuse
mais surtout d'un amour partagé pour les
animaux
nous aimons les chiens et les chiens
alors nous avons beaucoup peints en
commun nous avons aussi une piste de
course de chevaux où elle est venue
Elisa Swanson une Canadienne tenait à
vivre l'histoire avec un grand H je
crois que les gens oublient que elle
était une autre fan aussi
pas seulement pour l'Angleterre et
l'écossements aussi pour le Canada
alors je crois que c'est une maman
vraiment important dans l'histoire
canadienne aussi l'étudiante à
l'Université d'Edimbourg est triste mais
elle croit que la monarchie n'aura plus
la même importance aujourd'hui pour le
Canada je ne sais pas si
on peut fabriquer autant d'une connexion
avec
[Musique]
l'intérieur de la cathédrale une
cérémonie religieuse dite de réflexion
où les champs verser la douleur
cette première cérémonie en présence du
cercueil de la reine est maintenant
terminée la famille royale a quitté la
cathédrale de sainte jazz et dans
quelques minutes ce sera autour du
public de venir se recueillir sur le
cercueil de la reine Giulia
ont conduit des heures depuis
l'Angleterre et elle a obtenu le tout
premier des bracelets qui permet aux
gens de s'approcher du cercueil
recouvert du drapeau royal à l'intérieur
de la cathédrale
je pense que nous avons encore du mal à
nous résoudre à sa disparition dit-elle
surtout que mardi elle accomplissait
encore son devoir et jeudi il n'était
plus là c'est un choc mais je crois que
nous allons vraiment réaliser en voyant
le cercueil
son mari a souvent croisé la reine
pendant sa carrière dans l'armée
britannique
c'était mon patron dit-il nous avons
fait beaucoup de parades et de
cérémonies pour elle j'ai été près
d'elle assez souvent en performant dans
l'orchestre militaire
[Musique]
une dernière cérémonie donc de voir
auquel il ne voulait surtout pas se
souscrire ici Marie-Eve Bédard
Radio-Canada et d'Imbours